Next month, an international team of astronomers
will harness the power of radio telescopes
across the globe to achieve the resolution
of a single Earth-sized dish in order to take a picture
of the black hole at the center of our galaxy.
Imaging a black hole is a formidable challenge
and not just because black holes have such
intense gravity that they emit nothing,
not even light.
They are also surprisingly small
The Milky Way’s black hole, known as Sagittarius A*,
is calculated to contain the mass of 4 million suns
but its event horizon,
the point of no return
for anything approaching the black hole
is just 24 million kilometers across,
around 1/2 the distance between Mercury and the sun
To see something so small
from 26,000 light-years away
requires a telescope dish of global dimensions
and that is what the Event Horizon Telescope
is aiming to produce.
Because of the difficulty of coordinating simultaneous
observations at eight facilities on four continents
plus Hawaii, the team can observe for only
five nights during a 10-night window in early April.
The amounts of data gathered are so huge that
they have to be recorded on hard drives and
flown back for processing
at two centers
It may be early 2018 or even longer before
they know whether they’ve succeeded.
The team hopes they will see a bright ring of light
made up of photons
orbiting close to the event horizon
--with a dark disk in its center
The ring will likely be brighter on one side
where photons are boosted by the rotation
of the black hole.
Will there be structure in the matter
swirling around the event horizon?
Will the images reveal how black holes power
the massive jets that often blast from their poles?
The galactic center has a history of surprising us:
we may see things no one expected in the
very first images of its black hole.